The right way to think about this is of all the terms in the sum here,
you need to take the one with the fastest growth rate.
Log n is piddly as n gets big compared to n,
and n is actually pretty piddly as n gets big compared to n².
N² is really the only thing that matters here.
This constant in front of the n² is not going to matter in Big Theta world,
because we can go above it or below it.
Any coefficient in here gives you the same answer.
These terms drop out. This leading term doesn't really matter.
So really, this is n² .
However, in Big Theta world, this is also n².
Every function is Big Theta of itself.
It's very easy to sandwich it between 1.5 times the function and 0.8 times the function.
By the definition of Big Theta, this is true.
This is not true. This is true, because 20n² is also Θ(n²).
This is not. Once you multiply another term in here, even though it grows really slowly,
it's not a constant. It changes the asymptotic growth rate. This is Big Theta of those three.